j'étais prêt à tout je trouve que père
de sa personnalité vous c'est elle une
piscine puis l'avoir tous les atouts de
mon côté
cette femme de 75 ans qui préfère garder
l'anonymat accepté il ya trois ans de
prendre à duel un médicament
expérimental qui ralentit la progression
des symptômes de sa maladie d'azheimer
qui s'aggravait lentement mais sûrement
aujourd'hui ne regrette pas sa décision
moi je sens que je n'ai pas beaucoup
reculé je peux vous raconter je peux
rencontrer plein de gens
alors voici les bonnes à qu'ils me
donnent de jouer de l'avis encore avec à
peu près tout mon intelligence asuel a
été approuvé le 16 juin dernier aux
états unis
c'est le tout premier médicament contre
les amas qui peut freiner l'évolution de
la maladie
son approbation a suscité une certaine
controverse le médicament fonctionne
mais il est loin d'être miraculeuse il
ya des effets positifs qui ont été
démontrées dans cette étude lent mais
pas de l'ampleur qu'on aurait aimé que
ça soit mais il ya clairement des effets
bénéfiques
puis les effets secondaires sont très
minimes à duerne fait disparaître les
plaques amyloïdes un dépôt qui forme
d'un cerveau des gens atteints
d'alzheimer et qu'on croit responsable
de l'aggravation de la maladie d'un
maire des cas le médicament élimine
toute présence de plaques amyloïdes
mais il peut seulement ralentir
d'environ 25 % la progression de
maladies qu'on parle quand même de gens
qui continuent à progresser mais dans le
cas d'une maladie dégénérative si on
peut ralentir l'appréciation de 25 pour
ça c'est significatif c'est pas énorme
donc c'est pas la réponse absolue
il faut aussi rappeler qu a dû elle
n'est pas un traitement universel
on estime que ce sont les gens de plus
de 50 1 au stade précoce de la maladie
hihi qui on a découvert des plaques
d'amyloïde qui peuvent le plus en
bénéficier
habituellement les faits qui n'est qu'on
recherche c'est de maintenir l'autonomie
savent de quel genre malgré leur trou de
mémoire ils vont rester autonome
longtemps la compagnie bao jean a fait
une demande d'autorisation de son
médicament auprès de santé canada
si elle est acceptée les provinces
décideront ensuite si le traitement
estimé à 56 mille dollars américains par
année en vaut la peine
il reste quand même des questions à
répondre par rapport à l'efficacité donc
on va avoir besoin de temps là dans un
contexte canadien québécois avant
d'avoir accès aux médicaments
mais pour cette dame la réponse est
évidente qu'elle se soit pas la guérison
au je le sais que c'est pas la guérison
mais c'est un remède assez exceptionnel
si on fait prolonger une vie de qualité
des invasions vous avez gagné du temps
avec musicale beaucoup beaucoup plus ça
continue ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal
[Musique]